what happened they have this tribe when
our guns trained on a building police
officers move into position this was
just part of the response to a shooting
in which one of their colleagues died
SWAT teams on the streets of an American
city yet another story of deadly gun
violence in this country the gunfire
even interrupting this news report from
the scene as this ongoing shootout with
police you just heard another number of
gunshots we're gonna back up again you
hear the fire is getting louder and
faster right now the incident had
started near a cemetery and a
confrontation between police and two
murder suspects it ended in a kosher
supermarket the shooting having lasted
for four hours the crime scene is very
expensive and is at three locations at
least at this time we have one stolen
u-haul via a vehicle that may contain
incendiaries device that has since been
taken from the location and has been
examined by a bomb squad members
secondly we have five people do a inside
the store that members of the police
force that's set up eventually we
declared them do a we believe two of
them they're bad guys we believe three
of them or not that may be civilians
that were inside the store once again
this is all preliminary information the
officer who died has been named as Joe
seals a married father of five who'd
been with the Jersey City police for
thirteen years it's a tough day for the
Jersey City Police Department you know
these people work tirelessly in very
very tough conditions and we're gonna
notify the family but is one of our best
police officers and tough day for
Thursday in a tweet the president
offered his thoughts and prayers to the
victims and their families at what he
called a difficult and tragic time
officials say the Jewish community may
have been the suspects
security has been increased at
synagogues and other high-profile sites
just across the river from Manhattan
once again America confronting the sort
of violence that's become all too
routine here Gregg Milam Sky News